a few months ago I got a message from
someone in Slovenia telling me about the
tsitska a very strange and very sketchy
looking manual cable car across the
river server and I immediately wanted to
visit and film it the problem is it's
badly documented and what there is isn't
in English so I hired a local production
team who very quickly told me it's been
closed like most of the manual cable
cars in this part of the world it wasn't
being maintained and it was becoming
unsafe fixing it up to Modern standards
or replacing it would be far too
expensive just so a few hikers can use
it but one of the perks of having local
producers is that they can find things
that I really can't because not only did
they find a different cable car one of
the less still working ones with a
completely different and even sketchier
design they found a man who still
maintains it to this day
foreign
tomato
safety here like the sign says is on
your own responsibility this type of
cable car goes back to the first world
war the mountains here were part of the
front line and cable cars like this were
installed as makeshift Bridges but this
one's from the 1950s built after an Old
Bridge put up by the Italian Army got
washed out by a flood
foreign
reconstrator
construction foreign
and I know this looks sketchy it sounds
sketchy it squeaks it bounces its ways
but now I'm standing here it feels solid
I have no worries about this except if I
draw attention here could the government
suddenly decide well actually this is
against regulations and step in or could
some local kids decide to visit and play
around and break it or vandalize it or
maybe get hurt I've got a duty of care
to the places I visit and this is
something that the locals are clearly
very proud of a couple of them used it
while we've been filming most of these
manual cable cars are gone now and as
far as I can tell there's no definitive
list of those that remain one day
there'll be history but then one day
so will everything